Google is so all encompassing,
right?
You have g-mail,
you have android.
I mean that that is,
they are the number one operating system for mobile phones in the world on top
of being a search engine.
There's so much involved in that company.
And again,
like almost all tech companies,
they heavily lean left and they be,
because they had that don't be evil as a part of their code of conduct.
It seemed like something that was a good idea to have and it sort of defined
what I was talking about that tech companies are uniquely progressive.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I don't know.
I don't know what makes that,
um,
I think,
no matter what,
like we,
the Internet allows for a very healthy skepticism of nearly everything.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm from,
I'm from Missouri.
It's the show me state.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
I'm from Saint Louis,
Missouri.
We're all skeptics.
My mom was a democrat.
My Dad was a republican.
My Dad listened to rush Limbaugh and Hannity all the time.
I found myself somewhere in the middle.
But one of the things I appreciated,
we had a ton of fights and arguments and yelling matches around the kitchen
table.
But like I appreciate the fact that we could have them,
and I did.
I felt safe to do so.
And I didn't feel like,
I mean obviously they're my parents,
but they weren't judging me because of what I said.
And they didn't force you to be a republican or a democrat.
He didn't force me to,
to,
to think a particular way.
And I'm like,
I,
I think they were good,
at least showing different perspectives even in this,
in this union that they have.
And I dunno,
it developed,
it developed a skepticism in me that I,
that I think is,
is healthy.
And I have a lot of skepticism of companies like ours and leaders like me.
I think that's right.
And people should,
and we,
I mean,
I was,
I was formed through a lot of the ideals that they did and I just fell in love
with what it made possible.
And I,
I,
I never,
ever want to run a foul of,
of those ideals and,
and,
you know,
the,
the removal of barriers and boundaries and the connection that we have because
of it.
And I,
you know,
I think often and reflect often about my role in the centralization of my role
in our company.
And I,
I wanna,
I wanna figure out and help figure out like how we can continue to add massive
value and,
and be an amazing business,
which is,
is us and always be us,
but at the same time be a participant,
participatory force in this greater good that the Internet has really started.
And it,
it's not,
it's not led by any one individual or anyone company.
And that's the beauty of it.
And I want to,
I want to make sure that we find our place in that and we can also contribute
massively to an,
I think we can,
it's just going to take a lot of work,
a lot of introspection and a lot of experimentation,
a lot of making mistakes and failures too.
Well,
and it's very encouraging that you have that attitude because uh,
you know,
a lot of people I think in a similar situation would try to control the
narrative.
They would try to reinforce their own particular perspective on things and try
to get other people to adopt it or try to push it.
And I think it is,
it's very important to just have this open discussion and,
and I think it's very important to review your own thoughts and ideas and all of
the best ways to do so.
Put it out,
put it out there,
put it out there and have other people review.
Peer Review is a great process.
And Dad's floors,
the way this podcast has evolved more than probably anything.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's the thing.
I mean you,
you,
you did this because you want to learn from people and,
and the,
the platform that you've created,
millions get to learn from it as well.
And that's just so amazing.
Like I,
I learned from your podcast all the time.
And,
and
that's what technology makes possible.
But with that power also comes ramifications.
And if we're not talking about the ramifications and like at least being open
about what we know and what we don't know.
And I,
I think we're,
I think we state and post a lot more of what we know rather than what we don't
know.
And that is so interesting.
Why don't you guys steal?
Don't be evil.
Put that in your own shit.
Fuck you.
I don't know if that's going to help anything,
then what does that tell our employees that do?
It's real simple.
Don't be a dick.
Yeah.
I mean like how do,
how do we,
how do we get deeper and just like,
you know,
seeing more conversation around what is quote unquote evil.